The Joe Rogan Experience so we're
following and pleading with them all the
way out there
please just tell us please I swear on my
life this happened he gets in the car
door's open he looks up and the only
reason why I'm telling you this because
he died he looks up at Marco and I and
he goes it happened close the door and
off he went now the reason why I share
that is because
that's not something that I can put any
weight on for the documentary for people
like you right but as a personal message
for me knowing that level of validation
on the inside it kept us going it was
like okay why on Earth would he have
done that why on Earth would he say and
that kept Marco and I going and that was
a personal
level of validation that is there any
conventional explanation why the
military shut everything down why they
had military barricades set up around
that area
no they did try to say that the creature
was this guy who got like some
deformities
um but I've seen the guy Modine or
something like that but you talk to the
witnesses why would the why would the
military yeah I know I'm down because a
guy and then deformities and then for
the doctors in the hospital they said oh
there was a like a [__] having a baby
or something weird just something that
was just so ridiculous it was like and
you talk to the witnesses and they're
just like oh come on I'm not gonna you
know that's laughable at best you know I
mean these girls
came within eight to ten feet three
three women Katya two sisters liliani
and valkyria 14 16 and 21 they got
within eight to ten feet in broad
daylight of this creature
and one of the things that doesn't come
across in the film
when they saw this thing they're looking
like what are we looking at here they're
walking through this field and it's up
against a cinder block wall
and one of them was looking at this what
is that and it was crouched by the wall
it was weak and feeble
and one of them kind of like screeched
nah like what is that and it turned and
it looked right at the girls locked eyes
on them
Liliana grabs her younger daughter to
her younger sister who's 14 valkyria and
makes a high tails that out of there
Katya is 21. she's Frozen in her tracks
locked eyes with this creature and is
communicating with her please help me
he wants help it's we it's weak and it's
feeble and it's scared and it's crouched
down
liliani realizes that Katya is back
there she gets I don't know 100 feet
down the path she leaves her sister stay
here I'm going back to get Katya she
runs back and I asked Katya and I asked
all the girls
during that moment of contact when you
lock eyes I know it's only a brief
second but during that moment of contact
what did you feel like put me there
that's where the title comes from moment
of contact because that was when they
locked eyes on this creature and that's
when Katya said help me I'm scared and
it was feeble and suffering and it's
it's a very powerful moment and and and
these girls have been saying the same
thing the mother it's the first time I'd
ever reported on these so-called like
men in dark suits that show up and
intimidate Witnesses see honestly I've
been hearing about those cases for so
many times but I've avoided them because
it's got so much baggage from Men In
Black it just it's just ridiculous I
just didn't want to be associated with
it but I'd heard it I can go on until
I'm blue in the face I go until tomorrow
morning with the amount of cases with
generals too
but this time when the mother said that
these men showed up and tried to get the
daughters to say they were lying and
offered her a briefcase full of 100
bills
and they could relocate
um I don't know for some reason I said
okay for the first time in 25 years I'm
going to report on these guys and I did
and it's in the movie you can hear the
mother talking about it and she's so
emotional and the mother comes back to
the location where it happened the smell
that stench and the footprint on the
ground I mean everybody talks about that
stench that was so they said if you take
like a a skunk multiply that by like a
hundred thousand that would give you
some indication of the level of like how
putrid and nasty was paralyzing and it
stayed in like it stayed in the areas
like at the hospitals when they did the
x-rays and everybody talks about it that
stench though it's unbelievable like it
fills your navel cavities and doesn't
leave for a week
it was incredible and they all said the
same thing and they couldn't get it out
they couldn't get it out yeah they
sanitized the hospital the guy said that
he had to close off that Wing in the
hospital while they were sanitizing it
because it was so intense you know so I
I how long did it last for
I heard days and weeks is what I heard
from people and and even the mother said
when she when she went to where the
creature was
she said that the stench even there
after the creature was gone got in her
nasal cavities and she tried to flush it
out with water and saline or whatever
and and and uh she couldn't get it out
of her nasal cavities really crazy but
they all did I mean everybody talked
about that stench you know I mean
the military officer
the guy that drove the creature around
I was sitting across from him you can't
see his face but I did
and I'm looking this guy in the eyes
I'm thinking I could be looking at a guy
that drove a [__] alien around
you have no idea dude you have no idea
how did he describe
when I came back from that trip
people were like how was your trip to
Brazil
what was it like man they got great you
know uh smoothies and coffee and I'm
just like you guys have no idea
I think
I think an alien spaceship crashed
and they recover live aliens and we made
contact and the Americans came in that's
what I'm thinking about so I told
a couple people
on the last trip I came back I was just
like I was so rocked I couldn't re I
couldn't reintegrate back into culture
it was Joe I was just like
I think this happened
it's the biggest story ever so people
were asking me
even my neighbor who runs like the he
runs that Make-A-Wish Foundation he was
like James
he goes bro I like you a lot I got a lot
of respect for you but you lost me on
this one and I was like I don't blame
you bro I really don't but listen to the
witnesses just that's all I say just
and
and I would tell people and I realized I
can't talk about it
all I can say is just listen to the
witnesses don't take it from me
but I'ma look into that guy in the eyes
Joe and I've been at this for 30 years
I've made almost I'm working on my
seventh film right now
I'm looking this guy in the eyes and I'm
like this guy probably
trip me out so
and it ruined his life
he's he's to get this guy to go on
camera just like a week earlier
he was like I don't care all the money
in the world I'm never coming forward
the risks are too high how did it ruin
his life because you're harboring this
secret you're being watched you're being
told not to ever talk about this and
you're looking over your shoulder all
the time and they call you the military
calls you periodically they want to know
where you are
and he's got this Secret inside him that
he can't tell the rest of the world and
he's thinking about all the different
everyone's out there speculating is it
real is it fake is it real fake and this
guy drove a body around just think about
that for a second
think about the doctor who took the
x-rays of this thing
Marco Leal thank you Marco you're you're
the man Marco Lao found him
eight years ago
and he was like he confirmed the story
he was still working a regional hospital
he goes I'll never come forward
Marco kept going every year back and
forth and he retired and four years
after he retired he agreed to meet with
us he wasn't even sure he was going to
go on and I said look man we'll put you
we'll film you from the back we'll
disguise your voice showed us
photographs of him at the hospital we
know we've he's been we've been trying
to get at him
excuse me at the end of the interview
he said thank you I feel so much better
I've been shouldering that burden for 26
years and I've so desperately wanted to
tell somebody to share that story with
the rest of the world and you meet these
people and you think why on Earth they
didn't come to us
they're not trying to sell their story
We tracked them down and begged and
pleaded with them to come forward when I
found Martha
the sister of the deceased military
officer Marco charizi
we were knocking on doors I remember the
sound guy from from Rio de Janeiro he
was like you're out of your mind what
are you doing can't just knock on random
doors I was like man if there's a will
there's a way I'm gonna find this lady
and we found her and it was like this
kind of kind of sketchy area you know
it's like when you when you get out of
your car and you could see like people
drawing the curtains back and looking at
you and you're standing out like dude I
still like a sore thumb man and then we
walked up and I had Marco with me thank
God we had camera Crews and stuff it's
kind of sketchy and uh Marta appears and
her husband appears in this big she's a
big guy and he's got like a wife beater
shirt on and he looks like he wants to
rip my [__] head off
and I'm like and she's looking at me and
he's just looking at her going March is
looking Martin's looking at her husband
and her husband's looking at Marshall
like give me the signal I'll kill this
guy that's the [__] and I was looking
at Marco and I was like James you need
to think quick think quick on your feet
right now
and I said immediately please translate
this I'm here to give your brother
Justice I'm here to get the story out
please
talk to me and we developed a
relationship with her slowly over that
and those are the first words that we
exchanged and we eventually got her to
come forward we talked she'd gone
forward in the past but she doesn't know
who the hell I am I want to take you
back to the doctor okay what when you
talk to the doctor what did he describe
he said that that it was a normal day
January 1996 it was a regional hospital
every day and all of a sudden all these
military trucks and police cars showed
up at the hospital they come in armed
and they got a bag they got a a thing in
a black body bag
and uh he was like what the hell's going
on here that are you going to be taking
some X-rays
and he's like okay
and uh and they had him inside and they
had armed gloves and I was asking him
like what was it like because I when I
when I interview Witnesses I always want
them I always ask them to project like I
sometimes I'll even close my eyes
because I'll use their words to recreate
so I'm like living it through them you
know what I mean
so I'll close my eyes
and I'll recreate the scenes in my head
with their words right it's harder in
Portuguese because I'm having to get it
translated but I ask questions like what
was the atmosphere like was there any
talking no talking super tense
atmosphere very tense arm guards on the
outside arm guards on the inside
military trucks running nobody comes
nobody goes
and he said I first time in my history
in the history of my career I took the
x-rays and I couldn't even verify that
they were good because they took them
immediately and then they said this
event never happened he said the stench
in the hotel in the in the hospital was
overwhelming and he goes through the
different uh x-rays that he took the
abdomen the head the arms the legs the
thorax you know
and uh it was incredible in fact Uber
Rodriguez if you're listening to this
he's one of the leading researchers he's
gone quiet pekachini disappeared for 20
years did he get to see images himself
did he get to see them by himself oh he
saw that he was right well they didn't
open the body bag but he was he was he
said the stench was just overwhelming so
they x-rated through the body they
x-rated through the body bag so he never
got to see he did not see the alien and
he didn't get to see the x-ray images or
anything nope they wouldn't let him see
a damn thing
nope now there were two doctors there
was a guy named Roger Lear Roger Lear
found out these are people that I really
want to meet I mean people are coming
forward in droves right now we just got
two forensic Pathologists for the first
time ever working together to come
forward to make statements and they're
providing documentation of the of the
autopsy reports done on the deceased
military officer that's the first time
ever these guys are coming forward it's
happening right now let's explain what
happened to people who haven't watched
the documentary to the deceased military
officer yeah so so right after the three
girls came and came within eight to ten
feet of this creature or being or entity
or E.T whatever you want to call it
about an hour later that was about three
o'clock in the afternoon I would say
probably maybe around five o'clock there
were two military guys on Patrol on the
lookout for something unusual what they
were told they didn't say a UFO had
crashed they were on lookout for
something highly unusual and it was Eric
Lopes at the wheel and Marco shriezi
military police in the passenger seat
they were about a block and a half to
two blocks away from where the girls had
seen the creature a couple of hours
earlier and this thing runs across the
car in front of them he had slammed his
brakes on and without a moment's
hesitation Marco Cherise jumps out of
the car and grabs the thing with his
bare hands
yeah and he puts it in the back seat and
they drive it to a clinic and the doctor
is like what the hell is that get it out
of here I don't know what you know leave
so they went to Regional Hospital
and then ultimately I went to humanitas
hospital
and so we have testimony from military
acts that when he drove it from
humanitas hospital it's in the movie but
he drove it from the humanitas hospital
to uh as a military base where it spend
the night in the truck for one night and
then it went from there to espysex
Campinas it's like a university it's
where all the intellectual scientific
heavyweights reside and then it was
there I think under examination
according to the witnesses that we
talked to for a day or two and that's
when the Americans flew in to Campinas
and we have the radar military control
officer who came forward last year
actually two years ago when we were
there filming for the last time his name
is Marco fedes f-e-r-e-s and he came
forward for the first time and he said
yeah in January of 1996 this plane came
in USAF he kept calling it United States
Air Force came in it didn't have the
authorization of the Brazilian
government he was like this thing can't
land and some higher up stepped in the
room this is all this is his testimony
I'm just relaying what he said he said
some higher came in the room and said
let it land and it came and it landed at
Campinas and then from Campinas two
helicopters according to him flew to
Virginia Brazil Virginia back to
Campinas then they loaded us up in on
the airplane and then off to the United
States and that's where the case goes
called